Donald Trump now is in the lead for the
GOP Primary and the lead is growing
54 of Voters supporting Trump and here
is part three of my interview with the
former president this is the lightning
round take a look
fun quick answers and we'll wrap this up
okay
what is Donald Trump what are you most
proud of
I think that look uh if you would have
told me I was going to become president
I looked at it I thought about it I
never did anything never even close I
was thinking about it with Romney pole
came out when Romney was running that I
blew him away in the Republican party
but I couldn't do it because I had a
long-term contract with the apprentice
and I was building three buildings and I
wanted to finish the buildings and they
did good so I just couldn't do it but I
started thinking about it uh
specifically that I became president of
the United States
now I say what did I do that was great I
rebuilt our military I gave the largest
tax cuts in history I built the greatest
economy in the history of the world we
had just prior to covet coming in I had
done things the greatest in the history
of the world actually and we were
starting to get along with the other
side radical left people were calling me
for lunch
African-Americans Hispanic Americans
Asian Americans everybody had a job
everybody we were booming far more jobs
than you have today we were booming and
then covet came in and I had to do it a
second time and when I handed it over
the stock market which practically
crashed as it should but when I when I
took it out would I have had to hand it
over the stock market was higher than
just prior to covet coming in nobody can
believe it but what I did I mean so many
different things so it's very hard to
say specifically at first it's one thing
I did that I love right to try people
were terminally ill so many lives have
been saved nobody ever talks about it
people were terminally ill they were
going to die but we have a medicine or
bio and they want to take a risk give
them a shot we can't give it to them
because they made their terminally or
they're going to be dead in a month it
was very hard they've been trying to get
it for 54 years I got it approved so now
if somebody's very sick we're allowed to
use some of our very far out things
which won't be approved for another
three or four or five years by the FDA
all right you know how many lives I've
said with it so we've done so much
that's a big deal it was a big deal well
I'll tell you what I rebuilt our
military but I also added space force
and space force you know I created a new
branch of the United States military
that's a big thing we did a lot of big
things all right
I'm going to give names and give me
quick
short sentence of narratives whatever
comes to your mind Putin
well I'm gonna have to go a little short
but I got along with them great
had I been president he would have been
much better up because he wouldn't have
gone into Ukraine But ultimately he's
going to take over all of Ukraine gee a
man I got along again I get along with
him great until covet came in we would
have been able to work together very
well I got I made an unbelievable deal
for our farmers and manufacturers where
China was giving us 50 billion dollars a
year to our farmers and our
manufacturers
again got along with
along with I got along with him great
molos of Moran
uh different story there
religious zealots
and I think they might behave you know
when you mentioned Kim Jong-un he's not
crazy he's very smart
uh do you think any of these people are
evil like I look at Putin what he's
doing in Ukraine is evil well if I were
there he wouldn't have been doing it so
he would have been better off
and the world would have been better
look I look at China and the way they
treat minorities there as you know
modern-day you know inflation was caused
by energy when we turned off our energy
energy prices went up it caused
inflation and that was a whole big thing
and Russia became Rich think of it
Russia became Rich Russia made a lot of
money more money than the cost of them
Prosecuting this war think of it
um and we didn't have to do that Schumer
I knew him a long time from New York
always got along with them great until I
became president
uh McConnell not good
a tremendous liability for the
Republican party and for the nation
because he approved so much for Biden it
was almost as if the Democrats had
something on them tremendous liability
for both the nation and for the
Republican Party Kanye
now that you know some of the things
that he thinks and says well you know
when I was with him he didn't say that
and when he asked me to have dinner
because he needed some help I didn't say
well what's the problem so I didn't know
anything about his attitude toward I'm
not reading about Kanye I'm reading
about President XI and I'm reading about
Putin and Kim Jong-un I'm not reading
exactly about Kanye West but when he
came here uh
I think he and I will say this he didn't
say anything about anti-Semitism or
anything else and if he would have done
that I would not have been a happy
camper Barack Obama
don't know him well
uh don't deal with him at all haven't
spoken to him since the very very
beginning we did actually talk a little
bit the first couple of weeks but my
views are so Divergent that his I mean
it's it's just I don't want to hear his
ideas because we just disagreed I
respect him I respect him
but his ideas are so different than mine
it's easier not to talk about him
Michelle
Obama I like her I respect her uh
the first lady who respects her but I
can't tell you much about her she I
don't think she likes politics I don't
think she wants to be involved some
people say oh maybe she'll run that'd be
fine but I don't think she likes
politics and I don't think she'll learn
Jill Biden I don't know her at all don't
know her at all seems like a nice woman
Joe Biden
uh
I'm so disappointed what's happened to
the country
I mean the country
we were respected all over the world now
we're a laughing stock he goes to Canada
you covered it and he says I want to
thank China in the middle of the
Canadian why are you reluctant to say he
looks like he's in a cognitive because I
don't want to say that I don't think
it's appropriate for me you can say it a
lot of people say it I say it I think as
somebody that is
in the position that I'm in I think it's
inappropriate for me to say it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else